hola a todos bueno antes de empezar
quisiera pedirles un favor cierre en un
instante los ojos sólo un instante de
verdad hágalo no se duerman pero sí
cierren los
les voy a pedir que visualicen la última
serie película cortometraje cuento
novela o chisme que hayan escuchado
leído o visto que les haya impactado si
lo piensan demasiado ya no sirve tiene
que ser de esos que se le viene luego la
mente
ya lo tienen ok abran los ojos no puedo
leer sus mentes pero estoy casi seguro o
podría asegurar con certeza de que en
todos los ejemplos tenemos lo que hará
una buena historia
y una buena historia podría parecer
complicado porque hay muchos tonos
géneros estilos propuestas en fin
sin embargo si hay elementos que hacen
que coloquialmente digamos que una
historia esté buena o no yo soy cineasta
entre otras cosas doy clase de jong así
que voy a ocupar las herramientas que
uso en clase en el aula para decirles lo
que les quiero compartir
una pregunta que hago mis alumnos la
primera clase siempre es para que
contamos historias yo no sé cuántos de
ustedes han enfrentado a la temible
página en blanco pero créanme que es un
monstruo de la medianoche la vez hayas
echándote con la luz blanca esperando a
que digas algo y nada más no tienes nada
que decir todavía quieres escribir pero
no sabes sobre qué vas por un café vas
por segundo tercer o cuarto y cuando ves
ya dieron las 6 de la mañana está
amaneciendo y tú apenas vas con la
primera línea pero bueno si llegas a la
primera línea del título ya es un éxito
es el inicio de un largo camino en el
caso de que lo que está escribiendo sea
un guión para cine estás hablando de que
es el primer día de dos o tres años de
un proyecto que te va a tomar desvelos
cansancio sueño sacrificar fiestas
sacrificar vida profesional personal
todo con tal de contar esa historia y
todo para que para que algún día si
tenemos un poco de suerte estamos frente
a una pantalla si tenemos mucha suerte
de cine para ver si hacemos cortometraje
aparte
15 minutos y que alguien te diga
está padre
o que lo presenten a tu familia en la
premier mundial en tu sala y te digan
eso es todo diez minutos y no era una
película es una película chiquita de es
mía no pero si no importa que dedique
dos años desvelos que me endeudé contigo
con los demás que vendí el coche son mis
diez minutos para que hacemos todo esto
cuando ponemos la pregunta en el grupo
la mayoría llegan a coincidir en que lo
hacemos para trascender para dejar un
legado que contamos historias porque
esperamos que algún día tal vez
soberbiamente tal vez ingenuamente
alguien vea esa historia y se pregunte
orale quién habrá si esta persona
esta persona me quiso decir algo no sé
quién sea no sé su cara no sé su género
no sé su nacionalidad pero me dijo algo
con esta historia
según jan wagner hay cinco elementos
fundamentales para que una historia sea
una historia el que él pone como el más
importante es el personaje si no hay
personaje no tenemos a quién le pasa no
tenemos un punto de vista no sabremos a
través de quién estamos viendo las cosas
y más importantes no podremos empatizar
con lo que está ocurriendo lo segundo es
un objetivo y el objetivo entendamos lo
bien no es un personaje como que quiere
salir como que quiere trabajar tampoco
es un personaje piensa que es tarea bien
padre que le cayeran diez mil dólares en
la mano
objetivo es querer algo con todas tus
fuerzas
el personaje quiere sobre todo y va a
poner todo para conseguirlo
el objetivo trae consigo inherentemente
el conflicto el conflicto es un choque
de fuerzas generalmente va a ser aquella
fuerza que se opone al objetivo es decir
estamos hablando de un personaje que
quiere algo pero tal cosa se lo impide y
el conflicto es natural la vida
el cuarto elemento es la acción y el
quinto es el cambio para dar un ejemplo
que definitivamente no va a ser el mejor
pero es el que mejor conozco y más tengo
a la mano voy a contar una pequeña
historia de mi vida
el personaje no voy a hacer el yo de
ahora voy a hacer yo de hace algunos
años diré cuántos con tenía 17 salía de
la preparatoria
una contextualización mexicano residente
de pueblo joven sin mucha idea pues no
fue tampoco muy guapo
buscando qué hacer con su vida está a
punto de terminar y yo pensaba que la
música iba a ser mi camino tome esa
clase de solfeo para darme cuenta de que
no eso de coordinar las manos y el
pensamiento y leer partituras y aparte
el ritmo en la coordinación es para mí
así que regresé a la idea inicial que yo
tenía desde antes que era estudiar cine
tenía un poco más de sentido desde que
era muy chico investigaba quien dirigía
las películas que yo quería ver o que yo
estaba viendo también a veces me
importaba más el 'making of' que la
película misma así que bueno por eso mi
familia estaba de acuerdo lo veía lógico
y parecía una cosa que podría funcionar
sin embargo un buen día acerca de acabar
la preparatoria fue con mi tía esta tía
que te hace el paro para todo con la que
vas cuando te enojas con tropas decís
hijo tú tienes razón
con la que iba yo cuando no dejaban
entrar a la preparatoria por llegar
tarde y me quedaba con ella hasta la
hora de la salida y esa misma tía yo fui
y le conté voy a estudiar cine ya lo
dijeron que es mi papá estoy muy
contento quiero ser artista
hoy que padre y ya en serio que quieres
hacer nuestras películas si mucho lo de
tu arte y todo pero de que vas a
trabajar de que vas a vivir tú no eres
rico no tienes contactos no conoces a
nadie en el medio como se supone que
vaya a hacer algo no anda no a ver
ubícate busca lo que tenga más o menos
que ver me dijo comunicación le dije que
no busca lo que tenga más o menos que
ver y a lo mejor ahí puede desarrollar
tu te vas pegando y así que de su casa
salí después de unos cuantos horas
hablar con ella y con papá y le dije ya
hablé con mi tía le conté que cuenta la
universidad que bueno voy a estudiar
publicidad oye pero hoy en la mañana
decía sí sí sí pero ya lo pensé bien
porque voy a trabajar porque esto porque
el otro porque es creativo vea por medio
como una serenidad que tienen los padres
cuando saben perfectamente cómo vas a
acabar haciendo las cosas me dijo bueno
si estás seguro los vas
entonces corte a primer día de clases en
esta carrera
la maestra muy amable muy linda
bienvenida chicos es su nueva carrera de
publicidad que padre lo primero que nos
dijo fue solo recuerden que aquí no son
artistas ahora sí a estudiar
eso fue el primer golpe de realidad de
un cuatrimestre muy pesado y ese
contraídas cuenta de que el entorno en
el que estás no es al que perteneces las
cosas no pueden fluir bien no tiene que
ver con una carrera sea buena o mala uno
es lo que es y uno quiere lo que quiere
y yo estando ahí pasé cuatro meses de
tener que forzarme a ir a clases a pesar
de que por lo general me gustaba la
escuela intentar involucrarme en
proyectos que no eran los que yo quería
hacer perdí el trabajo tenía que
esforzarme por tener una beca que no
pude conseguir el semestre tampoco en
fin
así que al final del semestre una
profesora una excelente profesora de
esas clases trajo común que todos nos
gustan a las siete de la mañana
nos dejó hacer una trabe una tarea que
consistía en hacer un plan de vida
tenemos que visualizar nos a unos cinco
y diez años no recuerdo muy bien lo del
año ni lo de los días pero sí recuerdo
los cinco años porque era justamente el
tiempo en el que tenías que terminar la
universidad como querías verte y yo me
acuerdo que a una adolescente tenía
cosas como vos quieras tener un nuevo
viaje quiero viajar pero también tenía
cosas como
quiero acabar la carrera para empezar a
estudiar algo de cine y quiero estar un
cortometraje y quiero trabajar en cine y
cine y cine y luego vi la hoja y vi mis
clases algo no está cuadrando aquí había
una claridad muy grande pero al mismo
tiempo una incongruencia
por parte de la beca que sí tenía yo era
parte del departamento de prensa de
universidad en el cual tenía que cubrir
algunos eventos conferencias pláticas en
fin y uno de esos fue la ceremonia de
grado en la cual los graduados van
recibir su papelito
esta es una cosa de logística y me
acuerdo que yo estaba viendo a la gente
veía la familia veía a los amigos a las
parejas estaban contentos ellos habían
ido específicamente esperar tres o
cuatro horas para que su familiar pasara
un instante diciendo su nombre del
aplaudieran se juntará con un grupo de
otros 50 60 personas tomarán una foto y
a su lugar otra vez
y no les pesaba estaban contentos no les
parecía cansado las personas que iban
ahí por su pergamino simbólico estaban
igual de felices
algunos jugueteaban algunos no luego me
enteré que en la ceremonia no todos han
acabado pero eso no importa el asunto es
el nivel simbólico fue muy importante
y yo vamos a pensar realmente quieres
dedicar los siguientes 5 ó 6 años de tu
vida
parando te temprano haciendo tareas
esforzándote para conseguir una beca que
tu familia sacrifique para estudiar algo
que realmente tú tengas un papel que se
parece a lo que quieres yo me acuerdo
que la ceremonia siguió como si nada
pero yo estaba en otro mundo yo estaba
en un dilema y sobre todo está mal el
maremoto de emociones porque yo en ese
momento me estaba casando con el cine
estaba definiendo no hacer un trámite
académico que es importante fue parte de
pero es lo de menos
yo estaba decidiendo que a partir de ahí
cualquier decisión que tomara tendría
que estar relacionada con el cine y sexo
era muy frívolo cambiar de una carrera a
otra
pero tiene que ver con un compromiso
tiene que ver con que yo no iba a
estudiar algo para trabajar de ello para
vivir de ello bueno sí pero nada más
quiera vivir para ello y hay una gran
diferencia a los pocos días hablé con
esto paz
mi mamá tierna como es me dijo cómo es
posible que no estás pensando te lo
dijimos que se lo regalan mamá
por el contrario con tapa
y le comenté lo que estaba pasando lo
que había decidido y con la misma
serenidad que me vio la vez que regresé
de la casa de mi tía me dijo
tú y yo sabía que ibas a hacerlo ya está
gastado nos costó un buen pero no
importa si es para que aprendas algo
adelante es apoyo y evaluar
y también fue invaluable saber que en
ese momento yo ya tenía el segundo
elemento para contar una historia tenía
un objetivo yo quería ser cineasta
el objetivo como bien dije al principio
trae consigo conflictos
y este objetivo en particular tenía
pequeños objetivos para llegar a algo
más no dentro de otras enseñanzas
aprendí también
que el medio no es el fin y que a veces
esos medios esas pequeñas metas que no
nos gustan que no queremos tenemos que
trabajar para conseguirlas porque son
las que nos van a llevar a la gran cima
o al escalón que están más lejos
dentro de los objetivos estaba
evidentemente el conseguir la beca
porque nuestra situación era necesario
y lo conseguimos al final pude conseguir
una beca de 100% para estudiar la
carrera que yo quería
dentro de eso unas infinidad de
circunstancias que tuve que pasar mi
beca era cultural era de teatro cuando
yo estaba en chignahuapan en la feria de
la espera con la de la esfera con la
cara pintada una botarga haciendo un
papel de basura reflejaba cómo me sentía
pero no reflejaba lo que yo quería hacer
pero no importaba al final de cuentas
esos pequeños pasos estaban aportando a
que lo que yo sí quería se lograra el
siguiente objetivo forma de intercambio
una cosa impensable en institución
económica y lo conseguimos digo en
plural porque al final también sería muy
sobrio decir con frío sol estuvo muy
apoyado siempre
pero se consiguió
es curioso porque esta cosa de conseguir
objetivos de estar en contra del
conflicto de las fuerzas antagónicas la
forma agónica es digámoslo así el
villano pero no siempre es una persona
muchas veces es la circunstancia el
entorno el director de tu carrera algún
ex amigo tú mismo muchas veces la fuerza
antagónica pero ir lidiando contra ello
te vas dando cuenta que tal vez si
puedes que tal vez hay un objetivo más
grande que si puedes lograr
dentro de los objetivos
dentro de la universidad tiene
estudiante firme cuatro cortometrajes la
mayoría proyectados aquí a nivel local
en último semestre ya estamos trabajando
para un primer cortometraje más en forma
queríamos ganamos un apoyo federal con
un guión mío con el cuál se mostró
primer cortometraje a nivel profesional
el viernes tomamos la última clase de la
carrera y el lunes lo estábamos filmando
este cortometraje estuvo en 5 países y
estados más de 15 festivales la tesis
que también escribí dirigí ganó el año
pasado lo hizo de plata y estuvo en el
festival de morelia en alguna muestra
pero tuvo proyectada
hace dos semanas la semana pasada
externaron nuestro último cortometraje
en el festival internacional de cine
guadalajara uno de los más importantes
de iberoamérica
yo sé que estarán pensando hay mexicanos
que tienen tres oscar es en su casa tus
cortitos que
y pues si los costos no son nada
comparadas con roma con la forma del
agua de estas cosas sin embargo el éxito
no son los cortos yo no estoy diciendo
eso lo que estoy diciendo es que el
éxito que sí tuve fue poder tener un
objetivo
porque eso me llevó a tener el cuarto
elemento para contar una historia que es
la acción y la acción entendida para la
ficción es la peripecia tenemos que
hacer cosas que generen cosas que tengan
consecuencias según marisa otra es la
peripecia es el cambio de fortuna
si no tenemos esta causalidad de
decisiones no vamos a llegar a nada el
objetivo se va a quedar varado para
siempre y justamente para que una
historia esa historia para que una
historia no sea una anécdota nada más
tiene que haber un cambio y ese cambio
está en las decisiones está en ponernos
el objetivo y luchar para él
porque será que nosotros aparte de
querer contar historias algunos también
vemos historias porque vamos al cine o
vemos una serie y le concedemos un mes
de nuestra vida o un fin de semana o dos
horas a ver algo que sabemos que no es
cierto a que nos vean la cara
diciéndonos que ese personaje vuela
justamente por eso por la importancia
del personaje porque ese personaje se
concibe a sí mismo como protagonista
muchas veces esos personajes tienen
objetivos que algunos de nosotros no
hemos encontrado y lidian con conflictos
de salvar el mundo es un poco más
complejo que pararse a trabajar pero de
todas formas podemos encontrarlos en
ellos y pasan cosas cuantos personajes
que conozcan o no están allá en la calle
siendo anónimos porque no ha encontrado
un objetivo podrían ser héroes de sus
propias vidas pero no lo son porque no
saben qué es lo que quiere
este protagonista suena muy egocéntrico
pero no tiene que ver con ser
protagonista del mundo somos
protagonistas de nuestras historias en
las de los demás podemos ser secundarios
podemos ser hasta extras el que pasa al
fondo a dicen que no importa nada
pero la de nosotros tenemos que
protagónicos tenemos que tomar
decisiones
tenemos que tener objetivos
cuántas personas no pasan días semanas
meses o hasta años incluso décadas vidas
completas sin que haya una peripecia sin
que ocurra nada imagínense esto imaginen
que está la nueva serie de netflix
mañana y trata de un personaje que va a
la escuela o que va al trabajo todos los
días y va a la misma oficina todos los
días y conoce la misma gente todos los
días y como lo mismo todos los días yo
no sé si llegan al capítulo 2 pero yo
creo que a los 10 minutos en aquí te
porque nuestras vidas diferentes
porque no hacemos que haya peripecias
que pasen cosas estar aquí es una
peripecia bien divertida
y a veces el simple hecho de que pase
algo es suficiente motor para que hacer
las cosas
les pido que cierren los ojos una última
vez tantito y visualicen la última
historia en la cual ustedes fueron
protagonistas en la cual había un
objetivo claro en la cual algo peripecia
en la cual algo cambió
si tienen tantas que no saben elegir un
aplauso de pie
si tienen una muy presente felicidades
si les costó trabajo encontrar alguna no
está mal
están vivos tenemos tiempo
pero hay que hacer que esas historias
son interesantes que será la vida cuando
tengamos 80 90 años y no podamos hacer
nada sino justamente las memorias que
nos contamos a nosotros mismos cuando ya
no podemos movernos hagamos que esas
memorias son interesantes sean la mejor
película que podemos contar
para cerrar solo quiero dar una
sugerencia
vive una vida llena de historias en las
cuales tú seas el protagonista gracias